It might be the easiest word to say, and the most overused in our culture.
Help out with the school's cleaning duties? Yes.
Work extra late all next week at the office? Yes.
Bring a main dish to the neighborhood dinner party after your 60-hour workweek? Yes.
"Yes" might be the automatic, simplest or least painful response,...
...even when we truly want to say no.
But there is eventually a price: in stress, anger,...
...passive-aggressive behavior, exhaustion and illness.
Psychologists say that while women have been trained to say yes to others' needs at their own expense...
...or risk being condemned as selfish, men can face the same problem.
Start by making  choices. If you are invited to two social events in one evening,...
...pick the one you'd prefer to go to...
...and say no to the other by explaining that you have a previous commitment.
When someone asks you for a favor, don't automatically say yes.
Say, "I will have to check my calendar and get back to you."
Really think about whether you have the time, energy or desire to do what's been asked.
If you don't, get back to her promptly to say no.
The reward? Your life will be simpler,...
...you will be taking better care of yourself and your health,...
...and you will be living a life of integrity.
You'll also be happier to say yes to the things that you really want to do.